right we're ready again chair
okay right so we've we've come to a
decision thanks for everybody's
forebearance it's been a long night but
uh i think we've got there in the end
hopefully um right we've considered the
evidence from the police and also the
licensee on the representative
um we found a lot of the police evidence
including the dvd quite compelling and
clearly the historia has been very
poorly run
over the last 18 months and fairly
drastic changes needed
whilst there was a request for his
suspension we're not going to do that um
we want the licensee to engage with the
police and everybody to work well
together and and to
well make sure make sure that it works
with it with the conditions
so what i propose to do is i'm going to
go through the proposed conditions from
the police and i'm i'm going to ignore
anything that's already been agreed
and i'm just going to
highlight where we've amended it
so
the condition about um sorry no less
than six doorstep in operation
we're going to amend that to no less
than five on a friday and a saturday
and three on a sunday
or obviously five with the day prior to
a bank holiday
or any ten event so that would be the
same as friday or saturday
um the dress code including no hoodies
we we don't think that we agree with the
licensee really there doesn't need to be
no hoodies because huds can be worn down
so we're going to amend that to
no
caps
or hoodies can be worn
down
um
so the furniture tables and chairs in
front of the external area so we're
going to amend that to none after 9 pm
no alcohol refreshments can be consumed
in any external area for the purpose of
off sales alcoholic drinks and reset
refreshments must be in a sealed
container
and consumed
away from the premises again after 9 pm
polycarbonate vessels to be used on
friday saturday and sunday and a day
prior to a bank holiday christmas eve
boxing day new year's eve
and um to be risk assessed at all of the
times so no glass wear or bottles after
after 9 p.m
um so again that that will be that'll be
amended
we're not going to adopt the no vertical
drinking because we don't think that
that can be effectively enforced
um
the licensing hours we we're going to
leave as they are for now um
we do
we did consider this carefully because
we think there's an argument for
reducing them
but we would like to see how it goes
really and
you know obviously hopefully there's not
need for a further review but we think
that the other measures that we
adopt will will be enough
um to control it
so
just moving through oh door supervisors
so the timings
two at seven pm three at nine pm
friday and saturday
so that's the five for friday and
saturday
and the
the body cam so 50 of the licensed door
supervisors i think you've already
accepted two-door staff and one manager
so that's effectively 50
or or more
um
and i think that's it so that those are
the only amen those are the only
amendments you
we're going to give you 21 days to
implement
these changes
obviously the policies that the gmp have
asked for i think you you should be able
to give them or we would ask make a
condition that you give them within 48
hours
and any amendments that the police
require
will become a discussion with yourselves
and they should be implemented within
the 21 day
period
so
that's the decision of which you'll be
you'll be given that in writing
and within five working days
within that you have the right of appeal
and that will be
outlined in the letter
so i'd ask you all to work together
things that definitely need to change
and i think all sides accept that
definitely we can't can't go on
as we've seen it and things need to
change for the better hopefully this
should do it
um you can at some stage ask for a
variation if you think that you know you
you want to
extend the licensing uh
permitted licensing
um there again the police could ask for
another review if they think that it's
not working correctly
and we may have to reduce it back
further but hopefully this should this
should work
and if everybody works together i think
keep the communication
um don't ignore things if things are
asked for if questions are asked and
they should be answered
so with that i'd like to formally close
the hearing and thank everybody for
their attendance
it has been a long night
it's been a bit uh trying at times but